hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well friendships as
Cicero tells us in his work on
friendship involve a certain kind of
equality but they're often between
people who are not equal in every
respect and if we think about human
beings and the ways in which they vary
and the sorts of relationships they
inevitably enter into with each other
this is actually quite common one friend
may be more intelligent than the other
friend or have more athletic ability or
better connections whether through their
own affability and forming other
friendships or through their family
connections a person may be rich or poor
there could be all sorts of other ways
in which friends are going to differ
from each other
and Cicero isn't the first person to
discuss this as a matter of fact this
plays a major role in discussion of what
what we call unequal friendships and
Aristotle's Nick and McCann and your
Demian ethics so there's already some
you might say advice and rules and and
thinking about this in place by the time
that Cicero approaches it the person who
he is having talked about this Laelius
look to Scipio
his old friend as sort of a shining
example of somebody who excels just
about everybody else and yet is friends
with many people and he's taking some
advice from him so we've got this this
issue of superiority and inferiority and
Cicero says it's of the utmost
importance in friendship that superior
and inferior should stand on an equality
so you know this doesn't mean like
perfectly strict equality it's bottom
right they have to be equal in some way
or they have to be similar in some way
it doesn't mean they have to measure
everything out exactly but there has to
be some rough equalization going on here
now he does say that sometimes a
preeminence X : p I notice the plural
there quite um can exist and Scipio is a
prime example of that
even though Scipio tried to be more or
less than equal to everybody he kind of
stood out right and so you know you
could think about a seminar being led by
a really great professor and everybody's
being invited in there and we're all on
a first-name basis let's talk like peers
and yet you know there's a recognition
while this person clearly stands head
and shoulders above the rest of us so
you know there can be preeminence but
the the person who is engaging in that
isn't lording it over anybody and we can
say superiority and what Cicero the
focus that that he has he talks at one
point about virtue he talks about
intellect and gain iam right our mental
capacities moral virtue mental
capacities and then fortune would
include not just you know how things are
turning out for us right now but all the
goods of fortune wealth power authority
access social status all of these sorts
of things that
fit in with that these are things where
we can vary and a person can be superior
to another so the person who's superior
what should they do
Cicero gives us some very useful
guidelines for this he says that a
superior person in a relationship like
this is actually going to help the
inferior person materially and in terms
of honor and influence and he has a very
nice example here which you know we may
have a little bit hard time relating to
but in in the ancient Greek legends
which were also shared by the Romans and
many other ancient peoples there were
cases of demigods these were kids who
were essentially half God half half
human and usually the way that it would
work is you know Zeus was the biggest
defender when it comes to this but also
you know you've got other gods like
Apollo and I think Poseidon and some of
the others every once in a while getting
in on with with a human female who might
not be married if she is married of
course you know the kid gets brought up
and the dads like wow my kid is really
great but the you know the mother knows
that you know he's not actually the
father sometimes it's a virgin as well
and the big point about this is that
sometimes these are foster they're given
to shepherds to take care of and you've
got this kid who's pretty amazing you
know these Greek heroes and they do all
these wonderful things and yet they
remember dear old mom and dad all right
and they're not thinking dad usually
like dad in the sky they're thinking mom
and dad who raised me my adoptive
parents and Cicero says that men who've
for a long time lived the life of
menials because of their lineage and
family were unknown discovered to be and
discovered and found to be the sons of
gods or kings nevertheless retain
affection for the shepherds whom for
many years they regarded as their
parents right and such a feeling ought
to be much stronger in the case of real
and undoubted parents so you see this
when people make it big
they often by their their mother or
father
how
or a nice car or pay off their debts or
do things like that
and if friends do that within the
familial relationship they can also do
that within other relationships and we
could think indeed about some people in
a great great example or athletes who
have paid off a significant amount of
medical debts of the people within their
community or you know paying off student
loans things that are really holding
people back that is that is friend like
behavior on the part of a superior the
other thing that they do is they place
themselves on a level with the inferior
this can be betokened in a number of
different ways for example in languages
that actually make a distinction between
different forms of address one might ask
somebody to use a more intimate address
to say - instead of Wu in in French
right being on a first-name basis that
could be another thing particularly if
there's a lot of rigidity when it comes
to that inviting people in and having
them over for dinner and you know just
asking them well go ahead and bring
bring something you know a bottle of
wine some chips something like that I'll
take care of everything else as some of
my friends used to say to me when I was
in college bring your eyes bring your
stomach
that's if I should bring anything and
they said no no just you know look at
the food and I suppose they should have
said bring your nose as well the irony
is these are all like my Chinese friends
and so you know they were cooking and
making amazing dishes and they you know
they just wanted to share that with me
at that time I suppose I did learn I
didn't know how to cook but I wasn't
cooking and bringing in the sort of
things that they were so the superior
person places them something it's not
that they're lowering themself and it's
not that they're faking anything it's
rather that they're inviting the others
to be on the same level as them they're
treating the others as if
they matter as if they count just as
much now Cicero also thinks that the
inferior person has guidelines for how
they ought to behave as well and the
number one has to do with their feelings
they shouldn't grieve and the word there
is dollar II literally to feel pain or
sadness we might also think about
modalities of emotion like envy as well
they shouldn't grieve about the fact
that they are surpassed by the superior
you know they should recognize that it's
not taking anything away from them that
the other person is doing well that the
other person you know has developed
virtue to a greater extent that the
other person is more intelligent or
prudent than them in certain ways or has
different skills you know another
example of this would be you know III
have a lot of friends who are musicians
I am you know an amateur musician I've
never done much other than playing in a
few bands that never went anywhere and I
don't practice enough and and I can you
know recognize that my friends who have
excelled within the field and I'm
fortunate to have some who can earn a
living doing that and have done so for
decades I can look at their stuff and
not feel bad about what's you know
what's underdeveloped on my side even if
I put in the time and the work I
probably would never be as good as them
as a matter of fact one of my good
friends had a really interesting saying
one time he was assessing his own
capacities he was a bassist in in quite
a few heavy metal bands first in New
York and then in LA and then developed a
clothing line then became a drug
counselor he's done a lot of different
things in his life but just thinking in
the me the field of music he we were
talking about you know how much time and
effort he had put in and practice and he
said you know and this will be a
reference that people will get if they
understand the world of heavy metal he
said I was never going to be Steve
Harris good now Steve Harris is the Bay
and leader and the bassist of one of the
most successful metal bands of all time
in large part due to his own work but
also his his companions and and
teammates you could say Iron Maiden
right so if you've ever heard his
amazing bass lines holding everything
together that's that Steve Harris he is
so good that even in the 1980s jazz
bassist were saying wow this guy's good
instead my friend said I never aim to be
Steve here as good it was enough if I
was Nikki Sixx good Nikki Sixx is of
course the bassist of Motley Crue and
Motley Crue is not a band that you look
at and say wow now that's some amazing
bass playing but you say that's solid
bass playing it's it's okay it's not
stratospheric amazing it's not the top
of the game but it's not the bottom
either it's it's right in the middle
doing a good job and creating good music
doing the sort of work that had a
bassist ought to do if we want to throw
in some others we could talk about you
know cliff Williams of ac/dc who you
know play some very very simple bass
lines and said you know a lot of people
get on my case and say why are you only
playing eighth notes on the route and he
said that's exactly what we needed for
the band so it appears that he's like an
inferior bassist by comparison to Nikki
Sixx let alone Steve Harris he's not
actually he's doing what's required for
this band and so not being upset with
oneself because one's capacities or
one's contributions are not as big as
everybody else cliff Williams would be
an example of somebody who is in fact a
good friend right within that that
framework of the band he also says that
there shouldn't be a focus on trying to
be recognized for making their
contributions and he says that a very
disagreeable class of people are those
who are ever obtrude aroan services
which ought to be kept in mind by him
for whom they were performed and should
not be mentioned by him who perform them
as therefore in friendship those who are
superiors to lower themselves so in a
measure should
lift their inferiors there are certain
people who render friendships
disagreeable by thinking themselves
slighted right so if I'm in a friendship
with somebody who's say superior to me
let's say that they're a collaborator
and we're working on a book together
which is sometimes you know been the
case for me I've done some collaborative
writing projects let's say this person I
recognize I'm really the junior partner
in this this friendship they are way
smarter than I am
in life for example if I was gonna write
a book with Chris Gill about Hellenistic
philosophy okay you know I mean I'm
bringing much less to the table than he
is right but we can still be involved
now if I'm like you know insisting that
my bits and pieces that I'm putting into
the book be recognized you know and that
maybe I should even get like first
billing in the the title or something
like that I'm being a jerk I'm actually
trying to you know overlook the fact
that the superior person has come down
to my level and I'm trying to actually
go up above them and that's that's not a
good thing so Cicero to bring this to a
close gives us a general rule about how
we ought to handle the inevitable
inequalities within friendship and he
says that the first in the first place
we should render to each friend as much
aid as as we can so what we're able to
do this is going to vary from person to
person right and then he says in the
second place as much as he whom you love
and assist has the capacity to bear you
you can't always give everything to
everybody some people maybe at a certain
time or during a period of their life
can't necessarily accept that that that
help that you would give them and so you
have to be able to recognize that and so
friendship has to have a certain kind of
flexibility to its rule that allows
superior and inferior 'ti inferior to
come together
in a sort of equality but this is not
something that you can decide once and
for all it's probably going to take some
upkeep and maintenance and attention
over time in order to keep the the
things equalized out to - you might say
keep it on an even keel
you